[Musique]
précédemment donc qui veut gagner du
pilon dans la chanson popularisée par la
star academy qui a volé l'orangé du
marchand
je vais dire réponse est je suis passé
qui du coup k map votre dernier mot
s'abattent ces derniers mots je les
dires sa réponse c est grave et on sert
des mains de gagner pour honda lors d'un
million d'euros de bons gros pilon
félicitations de quoi laisser courrier
la ville ça évidemment
nous sommes de retour avec rudy pour qui
veut gagner dupes ils en ont mais là
arrivera-t-il à égaler l'exploit de
sabrina la semaine dernière rudy vous
allez bien très bien
nous jouons donc pour une quantité de
popo équivalent à la somme de 48 1000e
la question est toujours la même dans la
chanson du 113 jackpot 2000 quelle est
la rime pour la phrase suivante le
physio guy à la porte ne parle pas un
mot de français
2010 un clando un beau morceau mais ce
soir c'est sûr qu'il y aura réponse à un
débat passionnant sur france ô
réponse b du bisso na bisso réponse et
de beaux morceaux
réponse dès patrick bosso
sadate au 613 appel ce qui vous reste un
joker un appel un élevage 7 inquiète je
me souviens du but est de mettre 10 un
clodo maintenant c'est sûr qu'il y aura
du bisso na bisso c'est votre dernier
mot a dit non non non non c'est pas ça
ces deux beaux morceaux donc votre
réponse et qu'ils font rimer de beaux
morceaux avec de beaux morceaux sont
exactement les mêmes voir lé dakor gens
vous c'est sale mais le centre est visée
comme ça à l'époque
c'est votre dernier mot easy way c'est
mon dernier au brésil d'asie
dans jackpot 2000 du 113 la rime est de
mettre 10 un clando un beau morceau mais
ce soir c'est sûr qu'il y aura de bons
morceaux c'est une bonne réponse
bravoure
bien bout
[Musique]
veut dire on joue maintenant pour
l'équivalent de 72 que ce beurre voici
la question lorsqu'on utilise le mot big
g
on le conjugue réponse à comme un ver du
premier groupe là qu'on se paie comme un
ver du troisième groupe
réponse c il est invariable réponse dès
cette amère que je vais conjuguer piège
bien dures telles sommes là à dire que
le seul
j'ai utilisé mon dernier joker là je
veux rappeler un ami s'il vous plaît
souhaité appeler un ami ou dit ouais
pourquoi tu répètes tout ce que je te
dis tout le temps comme ça au calme
alors qu'elle a mis souhaitez vous qu'on
appelle en ligne j'aimerais appeler à
skip voilà alors on appelle tout de
suite notre ami à script est la réponse
fils de [ __ ] a rien à faire de la
journée du rsa devrait aller
ouais c'est qui ces mois-ci rubio wes
alors on se quitte l'émission qui veut
gagner du pillon j'ai eu des snacks
c'est quoi cette émission que tu la mets
en question foulards en soir
inscriptions jean pierre fulton non
c'était pas du 8 au 10 à skip votre ami
rudy à une question à vous poser
ouais à ce qu'il voit c'est quoi la
question leur verbe pic rabaisser du
premier groupe du troisième groupe c'est
un verbe qui se conjugue à oud bien
c'est ta mère que je vais conjuguer
attentat tue poisson mouvementée celle
là mais c'est dans la question c est au
fond tiger tu fermes ta gueule érudite a
dit quoi sont mortes et sain mais je
vais le bonhomme là tu fais le maître
nous lassons pas ce que tu es la télé de
la foutue connaît pas en quoi mais c'est
sympa ça le pull pas même une crache
dessus mais c'était la question s'est il
a un peu votre mii vrai beaucoup pdau
dit en même temps il écrit j'avais mal
parlé sur sa mère c'est normal qu'il est
le seul mais maintenant il va me falloir
une réponse crédit donc je vous repose
la question
arrête avec tes d'iran ou fois répété
question tout le temps je vais répondre
ses lacets voilà ça se conjugue pas le
dernier mot mais oui c'est mon dernier
mot vas-y ouais c'est bon c'est moi la
terre très claire des terres je vous
espère
lorsqu'on utilise le mot big rave on le
conjugue
comme un verbe du premier était la
réponse à ma bon quand même vous dit
vous avez été un excellent candidat
bravo donc enfin en plus je me suis fait
boulot c'est par l'autre [ __ ] là
mais je savais vous repartez quand même
avec le premier palier 1500 e de bons
gros çi de quoi vous mettiez en bas
c'est terminé pour ce soir rendez vous
demain pour une nouvelle édition de qui
veut gagner du pilon binaire franchement
jean pierre
500 e oui dans la merde traqué trop un
peu parce qu elle j'ai pu des masses et
un script tu peux tu abonnés en cliquant
simplement sur le logo là à gauche et si
tu as envie de revoir un sketch dans le
même délire à l'ancienne tu cliques sur
l'écran à droite a dit avant de partir
si tu as des idées de délire comme ça de
parodies tulle et lâchant commentaires
franchement nous voulons l'élire à et
puis on est là quoi